the impact of this is that we're always
seeking to tell another story about Asia
story that people are less familiar with
and in this way some of the curated
exhibitions that we take on may work
with a preconceived assumption for
example i curated an exhibition some
years ago about art from the Pacific
Islands and most people's assumptions of
the Pacific Islands is as an ocean of
paradise and so all of the works that I
selected from these artists was all
about kind of pushing this idea of
paradise further or kind of wanting to
disavow an idea of paradise so I think
that what we really want to do is tell a
different kind of story with the one
that you might otherwise associated with
Beijing in one of the most interesting
things to say about Chinese contemporary
art is that it really has this 30-year
history and when I talk about it we we
often cite the most important kind of
birth date if you like as 1979 when Dean
shopping declared his open-door policy
of China which allowed the opening up of
China artists in China at that time were
allowed to engage with Western art
history in a way that they hadn't been
able to before and there are these
important moments within Chinese
contemporary art that allow us to
identify three main phases defined by
decades mostly throughout the 1980s you
saw this kind of frenetic energy and
engagement with Western ideas and that
is often cited as the kind of most
experimental period and then throughout
the 1990s after Tiananmen on jun 4 39 we
saw a restriction of activities
that artists were able to stage they
were shut out of gallery got any
galleries or museums they really
couldn't show their work in the public
sphere and during this decade we also
saw the internationalization of Chinese
contemporary art that on the one hand
Chinese artists were prevented from
showing the work inside China but around
the time of the mid 1990s there was much
curatorial interest especially in Europe
and places like Australia and there were
many international opportunities for
Chinese artists to show their work
outside and then of course everything
changed in two thousand and there was a
real opening up of China and the Chinese
government itself had a different kind
of relationship with experimental
artists they decided that it was okay
for Chinese artists to show their work
in museums and we have since seen the
Chinese government take on experimental
of us as in a kind of national
representation such as if the Venice
Biennale the premier kind of
contemporary art event of every tree is
in Venice I think that we haven't yet
seen a I mean we've seen Stiles develop
in China that are peculiar to China and
have a resonance in China and tell a
particular story about China but I think
that the way that our production is at
the moment is that it's often harder to
export those styles we haven't seen that
happen yet in fact one might identify
other kinds of influences going into
China at the moment I think that
certainly when we see Chinese Styles
homegrown sells exported then we'll
really know that New York is no longer
the center of the art world but that it
resides somewhere else
artists that I would identify both of
them are in some ways from a younger
generation the first would-be self a who
is a young woman who lives in Beijing
and I think that her project for the
Venice Biennale involving second life is
really a great introduction I think for
us in terms of ways that aren't and
technology can work together and
certainly the avatar that she created in
her own likeness of course but I think
also ways that she has in other works
such as her photographs where she has
shown people actually in the factories
in China has been one of the few
occasions we've seen artists engage with
China's factories you know that's one of
the funny things about Chinese
contemporary art that although you have
this whole huge country diverted to
manufacturing in many cases it's
something that you haven't seen appear
in Chinese artists work and the other
artists i would mention is young food on
who primarily were works in video and he
i think creates these quite
extraordinary films that have that speak
in two ways or two side there are two
sides to them on the one on the one hand
they're very much about the nostalgia of
Shanghai as a wonderful place in the
early 20th century where it was very
much a cosmopolitan Center it was often
referred to as the Paris of the east and
he is able to conjure up that kind of
sensibility in his black and white films
and on the other hand it speaks very
much to shanghai's emergence is a major
financial center in the region and he in
some of his video works films I really
shows that emergence of this young urban
middle class or yuppies if you like so
that both these artists show in
different ways the kind of changes that
are going on in China but in very unique
that at one time especially if we look
to China's more recent history in the
20th century when the cultural
revolution occurred and there was a
desire to kind of destroy the for old to
wipe the slate clean and start again
with what were kind of more scientific
models and approaches to art making
however I think that this younger
generation of artists i think that they
look to history in different ways in
fact in many cases they're going back to
the classics and reusing them in very
different ways for example one artist
called hong ha has taken a very
important Chinese scroll painting and he
has inserted contemporary figures into
that scroll painting and so it's a real
bringing together of a traditional form
and contemporary everyday life so I
think that that's one kind of use of the
classics but I think we must also be
mindful that Chinese visual traditions
continue on and in fact there is a very
lively ink painting scene in China
there's a very lively calligraphy seen
through associations as well as at the
art academies and that's one of the
important things to remember about
Chinese contemporary art that there are
these parallel worlds sometimes
intermingle and intersect but we have on
the one hand the experimental
contemporary art scene that I've been
speaking to and we also have this
classical continuation a tradition
through obviously mediums like ink and
that's an important thing to remember
about
the one hand these this younger
generation is given a voice but I think
what what is also interesting to know
about China right now is that the
generation of artists who are mostly in
their 50s right now a lot of them left
China around in the lead up and around
the time of 89 and they left for
different art centers around the world
most likely Paris and Paris in New York
in fact and what's really interesting
about this is that there has been a huge
return to the homeland and many of these
artists even if they still continue to
reside outside of China have come to
work at a high level with either
business or government policy figures to
actually influence China and so I would
say that certainly that generation who
are in their 50s now have come of age
and they have a great deal of importance
important roles to play with in society
and within chinese society but what's
interesting about the diaspora
population is that they obviously bring
to china a different set of values that
has been changed by their living outside
of china for over a decade
you